o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito em mim jamais um vídeo e
eu os trato de que me inspirou muito e
xf 11 em deixar um ponto e xdr hoje que
os meninos vocês conhecem que os meninos
fofinhos e e e amarelos museus vão se
borrar a cueca por isso preparem pessoal
muito ruim no full screen e também o
tipo no máximo e busquem aumentem o
volume era isso que eu queria dizer
baixinho a janela se numa uma luzinha a
outra hipótese é lá pessoal declara que
o menino com testes e vocês já repararam
que o be que a fé não é o turno em que
está morto porque é eu aí minhas link
será que o link do zelda é o link o
inclusão do anjo selvas que eu e com
quem não saiba caiu vai viver alguns e
cooperação já passou de um bispo cor nos
cai ato vamos lá começar a musiquinha já
está pronta
a mulher é que somos o funk menem
pressionar em frente né
uol como é que é possível estudar passo
em frente e atrás de gol que levou o zeu
também não silva não inc eu não sei que
clinton tem a ver com os meninos méxico
não está morto isso pode acontecer
também em mim por isso vou sair daqui
não é e como é que eu sair daqui não
saio em voltar atrás agora é que não
bebe sensível e os ao tabu eo quarto
andar sem cheiro espera da escola que
isso não faz sentido nenhum eu vou mesmo
saltar daqui porque nem pra fazer isso
não é né o meu
o chão era ok é por omissão quem não
declara música para para vamos apanhar
bananas porque os meninos gostam bananas
exatamente tal e qual um morto
kai chen moneo xenônio e passei uns
crime tenha acesso a chama chama em
vocês
rui costa morto eu era pra viver amas
falhou ano e foi por tua causa tudo
por isso ter salvo mas não fizeste e
agora tu és o próximo dos eua começou no
dedo oc2 o próximo daí eu sou da ihf
ninja mas aí anda assim meu deus
a sega só para corporation de seguir o
que diz temer que eu sei é que o caiado
66 saiu tipos alta e 500g
não sei quantos atos para este estudo
com que cuca são é um mistério não sei o
que se vai passar daqui sair foi o
karateca não é pois é lá agora este
mundo com ilhas formadas perdidas no céu
e outro na já não apanhar isto ou por
ser um careca ali
este é o grupo é e uma ténue co porque
eu não me ouviu e tudo iria salvá lo oca
e seu grupo é e deve começar sempre
surge sabem por quê porque xuxa
perseguiu e não não quero é não
facilitar nem cabeça colocar nokia vai
parecer um susto eu sou e não ok é eu
também mantém o ing jan hein miami só
que aí o mato lixo e restos - só falta
agora porque eu sou um menino
supostamente depois de exatos 31 próximo
é comecei a desenhar histórias
a visão de negócio agora vamos pra levar
eu sou deus então a deus não é ainda
continuar aqui
não percebo eu tô com uma comissão para
no meu dedo estúpidas o calvário estou
está muito alto eu vocês não têm noção
está muito alto o que era uma vez um
gatinho fim a cair é estar preparado
para andar à roda voz próximo round
assim estamos ok remova mas já estava
procurado disse que estava procurando
intocáveis no jogo meu ok eu morrer
furukawa o z
o zé que eu nunca tinha visto morreu sem
cabeça
o link está com uma espada inchada tipo
entre o pescoço ea cabeça e pronto e
acabasse um jogo então é isso pessoal ao
justificar porque com isto me enquanto
estes ele o tempo já que uma explicação
muito rápida para o que está a acontecer
eu não ando assim ter muitos vídeos e
agora ultimamente porque estou a
preparar coisas tipo
o exclusivo já que o canal se diz
completamente diferente
aquilo que eu disse que eu ia fazer é
este ano e 2015 algo de frente eu vou
dinamizar o canal vai digamos assim
muito muito em breve vão vir mesmo
vídeos com o lar idade eu já disse
algumas vezes que ia ter dois vídeos por
dia e etc mas acontece sempre alguma
coisa que está errado ainda ontem ou
anteontem formatar o pc duas vezes
porque esta porcaria foi abaixo enquanto
tentava fazer render por isso eu não
tenho culpa mas agora já está tudo ok
por isso vou para os vídeos em grande e
só sabem o aek favorito fiquem bem até a
próxima é
o